sin luz y con apenas agua potable así se
despertaron los ciudadanos de quiebra
este jueves tras bombardeos atribuidos a
Rusia lo que empujó a que muchos
tuvieran que hacer fila en Fuentes
públicas para llenar botellas de agua Sí
así fue internet tenemos electricidad e
internet en la oficina pero no hay agua
donde vivo hay agua pero no hay
electricidad ni internet así que para
hacer café té o avena necesito conseguir
agua que me dure todo el día
y es que los bombardeos han dejado al
menos al 70% de los hogares de la
capital ucraniana a oscuras incluso a
hospitales como este en plena operación
del corazón de un niño cuando la luz se
fue que tuvieron que terminar con
linternas
en las zonas en las que el servicio se
ha restablecido los ciudadanos aseguran
que la calefacción sigue sin funcionar
mientras la ciudad registra temperaturas
bajo cero debido a los ataques sobre la
infraestructura que queda tacha de
crímenes de guerra pero que Rusia ha
categóricamente
quiero subrayar que no se lanzó ni un
solo ataque contra objetivos en quiebre
toda la destrucción anunciada por el
régimen de kiev dentro de la ciudad fue
causada por la caída de misiles lanzados
por los sistemas de defensa aéreos
extranjeros y ucranianos
asegura que el ejército ruso nunca ha
dirigido ataques contra la población
civil y que puede terminar con su
sufrimiento
los dirigentes de Ucrania pueden
devolver la situación a la normalidad
cumpliendo las exigencias rusas para
poner fin al sufrimiento de la población
ahora Ucrania Confía en poder reconectar
las tres centrales nucleares
desconectadas el miércoles tras ataques
rusos todo para poder hacer frente a un
invierno cada vez más cerca